hey what's up guys I'm kay PhD here as
you probably already have seen this
project from Google rooms recently made
public called Google glass has gotten a
lot of buzz in the last couple of hours
really I slept on it and I thought about
it and I think it's about time we take a
little bit of a deeper analysis in this
sort of augmented reality thing so let's
take a look at these Google glasses by
the way if I sound like I'm sick because
I'm sick so let's first start off with
the video that Google Pao for them looks
like the guy woke up and he was already
wearing his jeans and his Google glasses
but that's cool cuz I'd probably sleep
in my glasses too if i was a beta tester
anyway he's going along with his day and
then he gets this notification that pops
up in the corner and then he is somehow
able to bring this notification into
focus and then do some actions with it
before he releases it now when I see
this I'm really really hoping that
there's a way to be able to choose when
the notification goes from the corner to
the main focus because if you're doing
something important like oh I don't know
driving a car how you might want to be
able to leave that notification in the
corner for a while until you're not busy
anymore so I'd like to know if you like
there's some I guess ters that are going
on if this guy's like tapping his
forehead or if he's nodding or something
something to get the notification to be
in your control very very important
anyway he uses Google Maps he navigates
to this bookstore he walks into the
bookstore he's waiting for his friend
there and as he walks in he opens up
this dialog and says out loud to nobody
in the store where's the music section
now if you thought people looked
ridiculous wearing Bluetooth headsets
and talking to nobody at least you could
tell like there was something on their
ear you noticed after a while with this
Google glass it's kind of just like
someone walking up to you saying
something to nobody
nodding in approval and walking away I
don't know it just seems a little bit
it's the next level of that Bluetooth
thing I don't know what its gonna look
like but I'm definitely interested to
see how it works anyway what I liked
about this video were the tons of Google
services that I saw that are already on
Android like Google Calendar like Google
notifications with latitude and
navigation through Google Maps and photo
sharing through Google+ you know
instantly being able to take a picture
that's really cool and I like that what
I don't know and if I don't know if I'm
gonna like or not is how you actually
control these things you know if you're
blinking incessantly or if you're
nodding your head from side to side
looking like a crazy person I don't know
leave a thumbs up if you want me to try
to get like beta testing hands on these
I don't know how it's gonna work
maybe it's gonna be like a Chromebook
pilot program but I really really really
want to be one of the first people to
use this also Google glass will probably
not be the final name it's the name of
the project that Google unveiled but
it's also still on sort of a super alpha
testing apparently I was trying to think
of other names for it maybe Google
Goggles I mean that's already a product
but that also doesn't really resonate
well with the Android or the average Joe
Google Goggles like no one wants goggles
but I figured Google I sounds kind of
cool I don't know leaders so if you have
a comment if you think there's a better
name out there for it leave it in the
comments section below on this YouTube
video other than that yeah augmented
reality is definitely a future and
Google putting ads in it is also
definitely the future hopefully not
obtrusive ads but like we've seen Google
it makes a lot of money from ads and
it'll be interesting to see where they
take it from here either way thanks for
watching this video stay tuned for a
very special video coming up this Sunday
so if you're not already subscribed
you're gonna want to do that and I'll
talk to you guys the next video
thanks for watching peace
[Music]
you